Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 11, where we're going to talk about streams and filters.
So what is a stream? A stream is an abstract data flow. So data comes into your program from something called a source.
So that may be your keyboard, you may read data from a file, it may be a satellite if your program is reading data from a GPS satellite,
it may be a little sensor on the brakes of your car or somewhere in the engine of your car.
The data flows from that source, wherever the data comes from, and it flows into your program where your program processes the data.
When your program is done processing the data, then it sends it out of your program to some kind of sync.
Now that again may be your screen, it may be a printer, it may be an internet connection somewhere out on the internet,
it may be a little light or a dial on the dashboard of your car, it may be some numbers that appear in your GPS machine.
So the sync is where the data appears, the output appears. So you notice this is the input/output processing cycle that we've done from the very beginning.
Now sending information to a sync is called writing to the sync, and getting information from a source is called reading from a source.
So how do we do that in the C++ program? Well, your operating system, not C++, but your operating system has three global stream objects.
These are called standard in, standard out, and standard error, where the error messages are sent.
Now C++ has specialized classes which interact with these global stream objects.
And these classes know how to do input, in other words read, and how to do output, in other words write.
And those two classes in the header file Iostream are called Istream, which are objects that know how to read information.
In Java this class is generally called InputStream.
And Ostream, objects which know how to write information.
Now, as you remember from Java, a class is a blueprint for creating objects. And the objects are what actually do the work in your program.
So we can't do anything with Istream or Ostream, we need to create some objects.
And C++ will automatically create several global stream objects every time you run a program.
So cin is the type of Istream, it's the input object, and it wraps or connects to the operating system object called standard in.
cout is the output object, and it wraps standard out, and cerror wraps standard error.
So these three objects, cin, cout, and cerror, are automatically created for you whenever you include Iostream.h.
You don't need to do anything else to create them.
Now, these are objects, cin and cout and cerror, of course, are all objects so they have member functions, or methods as we call them in Java.
And so the get member function reads a single character from standard in.
The put member function writes a single character to standard out.
And if we use cerrorput, we'll write a single character to standard error.
So you notice I'm using the object and telling it to put the character, or asking it to get the character.
Notice we use the input object cin to get the characters, and cout or cerror to put the characters.
Now, using these single member functions is much more efficient than using the insertion or extraction operators,
the little arrow arrow that we've been using so far, because they don't have to, these methods just read raw characters.
They don't have to convert, and so much, much more efficient, much, much faster.
So to use these to read more than a single character, what we do is we use a loop.
And this kind of loop is called a data loop.
And so we create a character object, we pass that character object to cin get.
When cin get fails, then this loop will end, and each time we get a character, we print it out.
So this kind of loop, a data loop, is a loop that stops processing, stops running, when there's no more data to process.
Now let's look at those two member functions.
So both the get and put member functions return the stream that they're used to call them on.
That means that stream is modified.
So when we read a stream with get, it takes in this character, reads the character, and returns the stream after it's read the character,
returns the input stream.
Now, the character c is an output parameter.
That means we must pass it a variable.
And we can use this stream that we get back to check to see if there's more data.
And so this is the basic input data loop.
While cin get ch, process whatever we got.
To write a character, we use the put member function.
This also returns a stream that was written, in other words, c out or c error.
But notice that the argument is slightly different.
Up here we add a character by reference, an output parameter, which must be a variable.
Here we have an input or value parameter.
That means it's convertible.
That means I can call put with not only a character, like a, and print out a,
I can call it with a number, and that number will be converted to a character.
In this case, this number is just going to represent the ASCII character.
So this will also print out an a.
OK, so let's put those to work. That seems kind of theoretical.
We're going to write what's called the basic text echo filter program.
And the basic echo text filter program is simply this.
I've already showed it to you.
Create a character.
While cin get ch, c output ch.
So this reads a character and it stores it in the variable ch,
and then it prints it to the output.
And this, the cin get ch, returns a stream, which is false when there is no more data.
So let's flip over to our exercises here.
So again, make sure you're in week three.
Make sure you have gone to the streams and filters lecture exercise.
Make sure you've gone to lecture 11.
Of course, if you're watching this, you have already.
And make sure you've started the lecture 11 exercise.
And we'll look at this data loop.
So let's get IC11.
Let's right click on this folder A
and open a terminal there.
So there I have a terminal.
And let's open up this ceco.cpp.
So open it up. Here's our basic data loop.
And let's just do make run.
So notice the program doesn't appear to be doing anything.
It's just sitting there.
And what it's doing is it's waiting for a character from input.
So let's type a character, A.
That didn't seem to do anything, right?
B, C, D, E, F.
So when C++ asks for a character,
what it does is it turns over the request to a program that is at the source.
In our case, since standard in is reading from the keyboard,
that's called the keyboard driver or the terminal driver.
And so the terminal driver gets a request.
And what it does is it allows you to type in different characters, edit them.
And only sends the programs to your program when you hit the enter key.
So I'm hitting the enter key. This is called buffered input.
I'm hitting the enter key.
And notice that it then went and read the A from input.
It asked for input.
Now my keyboard driver had already gotten some input from me.
And so only when it exhausted all the input that I had sent to it
in my one input, my one buffer, did it stop and ask for more input.
So this is called a data loop.
This is called a data loop.
It stops when the input is exhausted.
Now you might wonder why it hasn't stopped.
It's still running.
How do we make it stop?
Well, at the console, there really is no running out of data.
The keyboard driver will simply say, "Do you want to type in any more?"
So from the console, we can simulate that out of data
simply by holding down the control key and pressing D in Unix,
which we're in, like that.
And notice the program ended when it tried to get a character,
it got the symbol, it was out of file, out of data.
So on Windows, we would do this with Control and Z on Windows.
Now this is not normally how we use an input file like this.
It's not meant to be used interactively in an IPO program.
Instead, it's meant to process data using redirection
to open and process files.
So the operating system facility, which connects standard in and standard out
to different files, devices, or processes, is called redirection.
So if we want to redirect C out, in other words,
so the source that C out is writing to is no longer the screen,
but something else, we use a little symbol here when we run the program.
So this would run the program, this would redirect it to output.txt,
this would create output.txt, erase it if it already exists,
and anything written to C out would appear in output.txt.
If we wanted to not erase it, and we wanted to run the program several times,
and simply append to the output, we'd simply use a couple of different arrows.
So two arrows instead of one arrow.
Now don't confuse these with the arrows we use for C in or C out.
Don't confuse them with the arrows we use for C in or C out.
Because first, those arrows go the opposite direction.
And secondly, this happens when you run the program, not from inside your program.
Now we can send the output that's sent to C out in your program,
and the output that's sent to C air to different files.
And we do that by putting a little number before the little arrow.
So one is called the standard out, and two is the standard air.
So we're saying run this program, anything that goes to standard out,
open and put the data in out.txt,
anything that was sent to standard air, put in the air.txt.
Now normally, when you run a program, both standard air and standard out appear on the screen.
There's no difference to them. You can't tell which one is which.
And if you want that same thing, but you want to combine the two and have it appear in one file,
you have to combine the two files.
So here I'm running the output. I'm sending all of it, or I'm running the executable.
I'm sending all of its output to combo.txt,
but I'm combining the error stream two on the output stream one.
So those are combined or duped together.
Now sometimes you might want to discard the output.
For instance, we ran the program Doxygen,
which produces a lot of output that isn't really useful when you're running the program.
I would rather only see the errors.
And you can do that by sending the output to the null device.
Now, unlike these ones right here, which work in Windows or the Mac,
this changes depending on the operating system.
So this is the Unix or the Mac version.
In Windows, instead of /dev/null,
you would simply use nul colon.
That's called the null device in Windows.
But it would work exactly the same way.
Now, what if we wanted to run the program,
send its output, and have another program run that output,
or eat that output, you know, read that output?
We do this by doing exe.
All of our output is not sent to the screen.
It's not sent to the file.
It's simply kept in memory until this program runs.
And when this program runs, every piece of output,
every CN statement inside this program,
would consume the data that was sitting there in memory.
This is called a pipe.
And a combination of different programs running one program,
sending its output as the input to the next program,
and sending the output of that as the input to the next program,
is called a pipeline.
Finally, for input.
So this would be a way to run this program,
and then pipe its output as the input to this program.
Or, if we want to run the program and get its input from a text file,
we can use the input redirection with the arrows that go the other way.
So we're going to modify our program to read aliceinwonderland.txt.
So, let's go back and look at our code.
So what do you suppose I need to change inside here
to get it to read aliceinwonderland.txt?
Well, that's kind of the magic of filter programs.
We don't need to change anything.
It's ready to run aliceinwonderland.txt.
All we have to do is change our make file and tell it.
So when we do make run, it runs from the keyboard.
If we want to do make read alice,
we run the program and we tell it,
"I want you to get your input from alice.txt."
Get your input from alice.txt.
Now notice we have not changed our program, CECO, at all.
All we've done is change how we're running the program.
So let's come over here.
Let's do make read alice, our pseudo target,
and now it's going to run exactly the same code that we ran here.
No change to our code, but it's going to get its input
when we run it from aliceinwonderland.txt.
And so there is the whole text of aliceinwonderland
printed to the screen, character by character.
We read each line one piece at a time and printed it.
Okay, now that's somewhat useful, right?
It's like the type program in Windows
or the cat program in Unix.
Basically, that is what the program looks like inside.
Now, and so basically I could do the same thing.
Let me just show you.
Let me clear that.
I could simply run the program cat, which is built in,
which looks just like our CECO program, basically.
And I could say alice.txt,
and we would get exactly the same output as we had before
from our own program, right?
So cat is a filter program.
So let's talk about filter programs.
So filter programs are programs that read from standard input
and write to standard output,
so they can be used with redirection.
And there are two general categories of filters.
A state filter will examine ch for changes,
and when it sees a change, it will take some action,
ch meaning the character as it goes by.
A process filter will modify ch.
So let me go ahead and just show you what I mean by that.
I'm going to modify CECO.
So I'm just going to say instead of printing out ch,
I'm going to print out QUIPR.
So I'm getting a character, I'm modifying as it goes through.
And now I'm going to say down here,
I'm going to say CECO,
and I'm going to read alice.txt,
the text from Alice in Wonderland.
So notice we haven't changed Alice in text.
I'm filtering the data and turning it into--
oh, it didn't work, did it?
Oh, I didn't build--sorry, I didn't make to echo,
so make CECO.
And let me do it once again.
So now I'm doing it with Alice.txt,
and so now notice we have created a filter.
This is called a process filter
that looks at each character and input
and makes a change to it, right?
Does something or processes or modifies that character.
OK, instead of that, let's go ahead and look for changes.
Now what we want to do is print the chapter headings only,
and what we're going to look for is a new line
followed by a capital C.
We'll continue printing until we encounter the next new line.
And so this is called a process filter.
We're not doing anything with every character.
We're only doing something when we're in a particular state,
when we're in the printing state.
So one of the things with state filters
is that we will always want to--
we will always want to have some way of maintaining the state.
So the state we're trying to maintain
is whether we're printing or not.
So we'll create a variable
and say we're never printing.
Now whenever we read a character,
what we'll need to decide is that are we going to start printing
or are we not going to start printing.
So what we're going to need to do is we're going to say
if ch equals a capital C, printing equals true.
And then if we're printing,
we're going to print the character.
And finally, if ch equals the new line,
we're going to turn printing off.
So notice how I'm going from printing on to printing off.
I'm monitoring the state and only printing the characters
under certain circumstances.
So this is not really what we want yet, but let's try it.
Let's do make read Alice.
Well, it looks like there are a lot of capital C's here.
So we really need to, in this filter,
keep track of only capital C's that precede a new line.
And so for that we're going to need another variable.
So here's my char ch.
I'm going to create a char.
I call it prev for previous.
I'm going to set it to a value that is not meaningful.
I don't want a random value.
And so we'll say if previous is the new line
and ch is that, then printing is true.
And of course, previous is never going to be the new line
unless we change it.
So at the end of every go round in the loop,
we want to say previous equals ch.
So this will let us look at the character before the one
we're processing.
OK, let's try that now.
Make read Alice.
Whoa, it looked like it works pretty good,
except for one sentence right here.
One sentence looks like it's broken.
So that looks like it almost does what we want,
but not quite.
So what we'd really like to do is now, in our example,
it looks like I need to look ahead to make sure
I'm not only getting a C, but that the next character
is an H.
If it's an H, it looks like I have chapter 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
So it looks like that filter will work OK
for this particular program.
And so let's talk about how we would look ahead.
So we can look at the next character in the stream
by calling in peak, cnpeak.
Now notice this doesn't take any arguments.
It doesn't take a ch like the other one did.
Instead, it returns the character
embedded inside an integer.
So if the integer is OK,
three of those four bytes will be zeros,
and the lower byte will be the ASCII character we want.
If we are out of data,
it will return minus 1 in all four of those bytes.
So notice it's an int, not a character,
but we use it to read a character.
We can put a character that we've read back into the stream.
This supports at least one character,
and we don't need to put the same character that we read back.
So I could read a character.
If it's uppercase, I could change the character to lowercase
and put it back in the stream, and then try reading it again.
I could read a digit. If the digit I read is a digit,
I might want to push it back into the stream
and use it to then read with formatted input
to read a larger number from the stream.
If you want to put back the same character,
you can just do cn_unget, and you don't have to pass an argument.
Finally, we might want to read and discard unwanted input.
And so this is the method called ignore.
You tell it the maximum number of characters you want to ignore
and the delimiter you want to stop on.
So this is usually when you're doing line-by-line input
and you want to discard the rest of the line.
The delimiter would be the new line.
So let's go ahead and do that, and we're going to read from Alice.txt,
and then we're going to change it so the output is toc.txt.
So that's going to require a couple of changes.
First, in our program, we're going to have to not only say
is the previous the new line, and is the current character the c,
but also and cn_peak equals a capital H.
Then I'll put the printing down like that.
So all three of these have to happen.
Let's go ahead and try that now and do make read Alice.
Ooh, that looks pretty good.
Now, that's all we have to do, but we want to put the output in a text file.
And so for that, we're going to need to go back to our make file.
And I've written you a stub here for the write toc version.
So to read, we're going to need to read from Alice.txt.
And then we're going to write to toc.txt.
Now, we might want to print some extra information on that,
so I'm going to do that.
I'm going to do tab, and I'm going to write some code out
just by using the operating system, the echo function,
and I'm going to pass echo Alice in Wonderland,
and I'm going to send that to toc.txt.
And then I'm going to print table of contents,
and I'm going to try and print that out.
So it's centered. I'm not quite sure if that will work.
And I'm going to send that out to toc.txt.
Okay, now I have a problem, because when I do this second line,
and when I do the third line, each one is going to reopen toc.txt and erase it.
So I really don't want that line or this line to erase my table of contents.
I want to append to it.
Let's do one more, and I'll simply do a dash dash like that.
So this is our pseudo target, write toc,
so we'd run it with make write toc.
Of course, we could just type in these commands manually, right?
In other words, the make file is only typing the commands for us,
so we can type a simpler command.
Okay, let's do make toc, make write toc, table of contents.
It didn't do anything.
Oh, no, that's because all the output didn't go to our screen this time.
Instead, our output went to this file, toc.txt,
and notice that we not only have this in here,
we have the other lines that we wrote to it as well.
Other lines we wrote to it as well.
So that's it for our initial exercise on streams and filters.
When we come back in the next lecture, lecture 12,
we'll continue and we'll look at reading and writing files.
See you then.
[END]